un pronostic le plus mastoc
werner le plus pervers maintenant dans
tapage nocturne c'est une séquence noire
qui traverse vos téléviseurs vous
connaissez le principe les deux impairs
de l'émission met le grappin chaque
semaine sur une star une personnalité
dans le but de lui tirer ce qu'on
appelle les vers du nez dans la cage aux
volailles
c'est jeanne mas qu'on a embarqué ckoi
tendons à thouars masse j'aime bien
c'est bien 12 j'en sais trop rien
ça veut dire quoi hamas ça veut dire
masse masse quoi masse comme quoi de
quel pays ça vient ça hamas dans le midi
c'est une grosse masse c'est quoi
c'était très très compliqué l'annoncé
des origines c'est quoi fabien d'origine
espagnole française française de
nationalités résidant en italie
émincer de son père se demande-t-on par
ces mots mon père du sud de la france
dire que l'enjeu sera tout ça 28 février
58 28 février 58
ouais ça fait quoi ça ça fait 27 ans
quand guy simon beaufoy sent bon je
mesure combien la petite fille elle met
65 sans talons après ça dépend des
tables ouais mais en général ils font
combien et talent ils font rien ils font
rien ma chaussure bloc ouest neige des
chaussures plates fait voir des points
la télévision j'essaie d'avoir ouais
ouais ça c'est vraiment plat ça vous
n'aviez pas et le poids le poids ça
dépend ça dépend ce que j'enfile mes
maintenant sentir un poil en devenant
poil sait combien je me pète jamais mais
je dois peser entre 50 et 52 kg et les
dents alors devancé bien meilleur de lui
même
tout ça mais cannes une barre noire mais
ça trotte d'être croqués c'est quoi tu
vas te faire changer ça donne ça fait
partie de mon charme et derrière ces
plans baisse et des carriers fait pas
quand ils tendent à voir footballeur
parce que devant si tu veux c'est propre
c'est vrai mais derrière ils sont
commentés cheveux là ils sont gras c'est
que seck cheikh seck les teintures ça
rend les cheveux secs c'est les abîmes
boîte à des pellicules non non non c'est
les abîmes va me tuer c'est un fait les
api tous les combien tu veux des
teintures un grand p cheveux ça dépend
des fois tous les jours tous les jours
ben oui parce que ça dépend alors quand
je veux devenir brune faut bien que je
fasse une tête ont produit beaucoup je
change une trachée
c'est à dire un cygne noir un peu quand
ça se fait donc pas ce que je fais dans
la vie il ya longtemps que ta pâte à la
main j'étais hier à domicile a dominé
c'est tout noir
j'essaie mais ça a commencé à appliquer
alors j'ai tout enlevé bon quand tu
seras plus vieille tu feras quoi pour
changer un peu tu feras du lifting tu
feras des implants de cheveux tu vois
quoi du lifting pourquoi pas eu d'accord
pour inviter tout à fait incertain tout
nous a pas dit les signes particuliers
rien d'ordinaire
voir plein de boutons sous la peau
maquillage et un gardien de but c'est
alors c'est quoi ça sa souche est
résistante c'est le fois ça va ça c'est
parce que le chef j'allais vous
rencontrez de bricoler ou quoi c'est
possible je puis quand tu as toujours
ses chroniques ses boutons du lsa
toujours ça non non non ça m'arrive
juste bon c'est un stress ça stresse tu
vois ses comptes et anthrax a fait ça
n'ont pas le stress monte sur sa fête tu
veux vraiment savoir
oui c'est quand je vais avoir mes règles
finalement c'est la vie même si je les
uns par les glaces nous tournons vers
aussi elle n'aurait pu redémarrer à la
corde et surtout on parle de paille
voilà presque sept ans 18 ans u18 et
puis petit à petit j'ai abandonné pour
l'après plein de choses tu as appris ce
que c'était par exemple qu une
périphrase qu'est ce que c'est une
périphrase je sais pas si tu sais ce que
c'est ces remous français c'est pas ta
bagnole périphrase je sais pas expliquer
mon amie tombe à la police que c'est une
victoire c'est parce que si jamais si
terribles préfigurent la bac tu dois en
plus à un syllogisme c'est quoi ça c'est
facile syllogisme ça non plus je connais
pas bien entendu parler quand même mais
non non pas du tout un tropisme non plus
ça va et vous êtes écrit les truites ont
été les chercher dans le dictionnaire
concerne directement parce que tu es une
fille que vous avez tout à l'heure oui
je sais c'est une femme l'onanisme c'est
quoi ça c'est déjà plus facile
as tu sais ce que c'est clair l'onanisme
c'est un truc de filles dont entre
autres c'est ce que c'est vous organisme
c'est parce que l'analyse m'ont écouté
donnez moi les explications tout ça on
analyse la francia la flamme c'est un
jean brad et vonesch parce que c'est la
gironde est bonne la charente au feeling
c'est ce que c'est non plus mais je
voudrais que vous m'expliquiez tous à la
géronto à des gens qui ne peuvent faire
l'amour qu'avec des vieillards
oui c'est greg d'origine il faut bien le
dire d'accord tu sais pas ça non je suis
pas très branché là dessus sur la
gérontophilie la zoophilie par exemple
tu vois ce que ça peut être n'ont plus
rien à faire la connerie elle a perdu un
certain qu'en des tudors comment toi ça
dépend quand tu es quelqu'un à côté de
moi je mets un pyjama copier personne je
me mets un poids annoncé pour la mère
n'ont certes pas bien compris de
questions là mais s'il préfère l'herbe
le shit le suit le shit lequel devrait
faire le marocain le maroc ou bien le
noir à côte le noir super mais il ya un
truc en italie on l'appelle en liant
alors la cdm en cd - c'est des montures
rigole c'est pas pour bientôt
je sais pas mon blog à bamako d'échelle
ospina grave en france non s'achète pas
on le donne
ouais on achète pour toi ton âge est
pour toi non on mâche est absolument
rien de tout ça genre de dépenser de
l'argent pour ça on me l'offre
j'ai des amis qui m'ont offre et je
trouve ça très juteux les autres
dépenses pour toi ça va mais toi tu
dépends ce passage était donc tu gardes
ton argent pour autre chose pour donner
une avance de plus de 10 oui mais câline
entre l'offre je ne tiens un jeune et
génial est ok ça ne fait pas rigoler non
ça ne fait pas rigoler temps déjà une
personne assez speed
j'ai pas besoin ils préfèrent l'héroïne
cette can gd kazan africaine comme temps
après j'ai pas pris de cocaïne jamais
essayé de ta vie s'il ya très très
longtemps
non pas celle ci c'est ce que j'ai avec
la coop s'est trompé ma cigarette comme
sa différence importante ou pas
importante entre chez pas le pen et
marché par exemple parce que c'est pas
très loin ou est ce que c'est vrai c'est
différent ou très différents le seul
problème là dedans c'est que pour moi
c'est pas un problème tu vois j'arrive
très bien à vivre sans ses joueurs comme
différents lieux gens ne viennent pas
pour eelv alors imagine qui est au
pouvoir demain je sais pas marcher par
exemple étant foutrait autant
qu'aujourd'hui tu pourrais pu lire les
journaux que tu veux c'est pas grave
donc tu peux me rends compte que tu lis
pas le journal en bref des gens comme
toi qu'ils arrivent les russes viennent
à paris ça ne dérange pas dans le yes
l'éclatant foulée rouzier d'appareils ça
te dérange pas les remplir il y aura
peut-être juste un problème de langage
j'apprends passé que je viens de te voir
c'est ça qu'ils achètent et discutent en
fait j'aurais changé de vie je dit pas
si les résidents arrivent ce que je veux
gagner tu vois ça chantait pour la
gestapo gang avec les raisonnements
comme heures
vrai qu'il y en a rien d'autre part dont
tu crois qu'il y en aura une ou deux
guerres nom de gustavo bas ça s'appelle
le kgb mais c'est la même chose
bon d'accord bah écoute si on me demande
urgente de boer bah écoute les gens sont
toujours des gens le papier le pointu
chantera la fête de l'humanité toi je
chanterai je chanterai pour le peuple je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas ce genre de
principe que ce soit la fête de
l'humanité où la fête d'autres choses tu
vois je chanterai à la fête bleue blanc
rouge de l'open mais oui elle vient de
le dire donc 42 alors je n'étais pas
législation la socialie cette chambre
pour l'open gt ça c'est très bien on a
compris bon alors ton fiancé tu l'a
connu quand et où le club a suivi avec
qui tu es en ce moment bonne blague
en ce moment je suis avec personne
théorique personnes ils ont personne
parce que j'en ai plusieurs en même
temps tu comprends vie que je divise ma
vie entre la france et l'italie je suis
français d'en avoir plus d'un mois ça
fait 2 saoudite a mis en france
mettaient bien vite aller mais je fais
de la promo aussi en allemagne j'en fais
aussi au canada j'en fais aussi dans le
reste de leur a donc tu comprends
j'aille dans chaque port tout à fait tu
trouve sa propre carte est pas fidèles
en fait ça alors que la fidélité c'est
démodé fait démonter bombe apparemment
de suite l'italie alors il est comment
il s'appelle mario il s'appelle comment
alain bertho comment tu sais maintenant
allez donc comment tu le sais qu'ils
appellent alberto s'appelle comment oui
s'appelle alberto il fait quoi
il travaille dans la mode du styliste
non non il ya des magasins la baie des
doigts et coûtent jusqu'à présent ça va
donc il s'en sort bien tu fais les deux
les [ __ ] déroule avec moi il ne fait
qu'une seule chose il est hétéro et puis
s'il fait payer des pins derrière c'est
pas grave je vais peut-être derrière lui
ai dit non tu es plutôt le sentiment
d'être quito riediennes ou vaginale
comme suivre je pense tout les tous les
deux tous les deux ouais ça dépend tu
penses mais je te dire que tu te feras
pas d'un côté mais vaut essayer donc
tout à fait de l'autre et à mal aussi
et non on ne touche pas quand même tu
vois
ça te dégoûte c'est pas que ça me
dégoûte c'est que ça me dégoûte rue
peut-être que ça me dégoûte n'a jamais
proposé bas bien sûr comme l'a proposé
et alors on te demande pas de dire que
je refais non là non parce que ça fait
mal parce que ça te dégoûte non parce
que je trouve que j'ai autre chose à
proposer
on a fait le tour de tous après vous
avez ça fait trois mois avec le même mec
bas trois mois avec le maître même non
non on a toujours des choses à apprendre
on n'a pas besoin dans un très loin où
viennent de se retourner pour mars
j'ai dit à m on se renseigne en mai là
pour ça ouais qu'est ce que tu veux t'en
qu'est ce que tu as eu déjà des
expériences homosexuelles
oui il veut également que oui mais non
et 4 passes pour l'instant jamais non
jamais non jamais plaint une équipe
poussée qui rougit est inconnue combien
de gars on attendait plutôt une dizaine
une centaine une cinquantaine 5
il s'agirait non attends à peu près je
pêche peut rafler pas compris sur la loi
et aux besoins de nos malades
oui j'aurais peut-être fait qu'on ne
demande pas distrait ben laden garçon tu
penses 50 m c'est mais pas flirté hier
jeudi y retrouve qui dit que chez
bouygues on a couché kouchner entre
adultes à la fin bush est couché 49 à
leurs 49 important la taille du sexe de
l'homme vu que je pense également tu vas
que les hommes ont tué petit sûrement
oui oui non mais ça c'est un problème je
veux dire le fait d'être petite
houppette
je pense que les hommes de sami baptisé
leur sexe ch parts égales lorsqu'il est
plus puissant que 1 2 qui est un énième
problème est moins de problèmes pour ces
gros oui c'est le plus mal en ce moment
ça dépend qui essayait de très bonne
crème de la place
c'est un décret mais je pense pas qu'il
a dans les sex-shops chez des non non ça
c'est mon gynéco qui me wade a tenu dans
les déserts de 10 mètres carrés pendant
un mois avec la nomme lequel tu
préfèrerais de brou les hommes qui
assurent terrain tu peux choisir
gorbatchev puisque c'est ton copain et
charge et à décharge et un français un
français tu vas passer normalement si
c'était un français christophe lambert
christophe lambert ce qui sera le tarzan
tu lâches et là il te plait je fais
craquer dans tarzan oui voilà voilà
j'arrive moi tarzan toi jane the end
c'est ainsi que s'achève descente de
police merci à jeanne mas d'avoir joué
le jeu et corrections de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou